tholot comme des grands en alliant avons
chanté mireille et pour faire plaisir
lire ce qui suit à la feuille m olé
ça parce que ça faisait gagner une
minute informez-vous leur ferme à prague
quand elle passe la carmencita elle
déplace 100000 gare lucide s'enflamme
puissent être les deux elle criait
anthony dale goûts et les chairs haut
comme illégaux et aux années
chaque semaine est de l île à l'aide des
couleurs madrilènes
tu connais pas me faire virer
mireille mireille ok merveille
le hand lorsque mon coeur sommeil j'ai
le train de masser je me réveillais
irait dans mes bras attendez qu à plein
temps double guichet comme à grain à
tout petits pas attraper vincent
bilodeau dessous on est quelque part oui
vous savez y est allé voir un chai des
mimosas ou des t bills 1 je suis
complètement perdue parce que je sais
pas j'ai chanté cette chanson c'est un
gars que je me souviens pas de monter
mais que marciac souffler bois au lieu
de vous marrer du lot tu connais pas
venir que mireille direct direct les
rebelles
lorsque mon
c'est le train de marseille aucun je me
réveille irait dans mes bras si tu as
fait
non
et son ego et envoûtant
du vernet dans ce coup les milieux
oui de la perse est de la rabine c'est
immense baignoire l irene alors sous le
poids de la chine en ce 10 devant le
mystérieux dans le fond je suis presque
sûr qu'elle ait eu des yeux qui collait
pas mireille vous vraiment merdé la
7ième même que je suis tellement ému que
qu'un juge atteinte au renom jeu pas
trompée dans les paroles quand
j'évoquais sommeil j'ai le train de
marseille
et quand je me réveille pyrénées dans
je pense que mon père ma mère des
milliers téléspectateurs me regarde je
suis je vois là j'ai ma carrière et
ruiné qu'est ce que fait monsieur
carrière faut que je chatte autre chose
ou bien est-ce que c'est fini j'avais
plus maintenant